Parfait.
Il n'y a pas un nuage, le temps idéal
pour un arc-en-ciel.
Si, si ! Un arc-en-ciel
que nous allons fabriquer.
Mais non !
Pas avec
des crayons de couleur !
Suivez-moi.
Et voilà,
je suis prêt.
Pour faire pousser un arc-en-ciel il faut de l’eau
sous forme de gouttelettes et du soleil,
enfin la lumière
émise par le Soleil. C'est parti.
La lumière pénètre dans les gouttes d’eau, se réfléchit côté opposé avant de ressortir à l’air libre.
Chaque goutte agit un peu
comme un miroir.
Par conséquent, pour observer un arc-en-ciel, l’observateur doit se trouver
entre le soleil et le rideau de pluie, le dos
tourné au soleil et le regard orienté vers la pluie.
Si cet agencement change,
l’arc-en-ciel disparaît.
La preuve :
quand la petite caméra bouge,
l'arc-en-ciel
n'est plus visible.
Allez, on en profite
encore un peu ?
C’est beau !
Alors, d’où sortent toutes ces couleurs ?
Une goutte d'eau est pourtant
parfaitement incolore.
En fait, la lumière émise par le soleil est blanche.
Tous les spationautes vous le confirmeront.
Le Soleil qu’ils voient se lever 16 fois par jour
à bord de la station spatiale internationale
est blanc et non pas jaune,
comme sur les tableaux des grands peintres.
Alors,
nous auraient-ils menti ?
Et voilà le spectre
du grand complot qui ressurgit.
Eh bien non. Vu du plancher des vaches,
le Soleil est bien jaune, et non pas blanc.
C’est parce que la lumière blanche
est constituée de plusieurs couleurs,
les fameuses couleurs
de l’arc-en-ciel.
Seulement, avant d’arriver jusqu’à nous, certaines ondes, celles qui correspondent à la couleur bleue,
sont déviées et diffusées
par l’atmosphère.
Privée d’une partie du bleu,
la lumière blanche tire sur le jaune.
Mais revenons aux couleurs
de l’arc-en-ciel.
Quand elle pénètre dans une goutte d’eau,
la lumière change de milieu.
Elle passe de l’air à l’eau puis, de l’eau à l’air.
À ce moment-là, elle est déviée.
C’est un phénomène
que vous connaissez tous très bien :
quand un bâton est plongé dans l’eau, vu de l’extérieur, il semble brisé parce que la lumière est déviée.
Les ondes, qui correspondent aux différentes
couleurs qui composent la lumière blanche,
sont toutes
déviées différemment.
Le violet est davantage dévié que le vert
qui l’est davantage que le jaune, etc…
Du coup, les couleurs sont séparées et elles sont toutes réfléchies dans des directions légèrement différentes.
C’est ce qui donne naissance à un arc-en-ciel
et permet d’observer le spectre de la lumière visible.
Maintenant, un peu d’Histoire…
C’est le savant anglais Isaac Newton, qui en 1660,
a le premier expliqué le phénomène.
Le même qui un peu plus tard va formuler
« la loi de l’attraction universelle »
en observant, nous dit la légende,
la chute d’une pomme.
C’est pour cette raison que j’ai accroché son portrait
au milieu des pommiers,
pour situer le personnage plus facilement.
Pour illustrer sa théorie
sur la composition de la lumière,
Isaac Newton s’appuie sur
une expérience qu’il réalise en public
et qui consiste à faire passer
de la lumière à travers un prisme.
Comme ceci.
Mais il a beau faire l’expérience
dans un sens ou dans un autre,
décomposer ou
recomposer la lumière,
en 1660, l’idée a un peu de mal
à passer dans la population.
Surtout quand il explique qu’un arc-en-ciel n’est rien d’autre que l’illustration de ce phénomène.
Pour convaincre ses contemporains,
il imagine un petit disque,
qui depuis porte son nom
et sur lequel il peint les couleurs de l’arc-en-ciel.
En le faisant tourner rapidement - évidemment, à l’époque il n’a pas de moteur électrique –
tout devient clair
comme de l’eau de roche.
Enfin... blanc
comme du lait de vache.
Violet,
bleu, vert,
jaune, orange, rouge…
six couleurs.
Il en manque une pour compléter
le spectre de l’arc-en-ciel : l’indigo.
Alors, pourquoi avoir ajouté une 7ème couleur
entre le violet et le bleu
et pas une 8ème entre le bleu et le vert,
une 9ème entre le vert et le jaune, etc… ?
Certains experts rappellent que
Newton était également théologien.
Or le chiffre 7, dans la religion chrétienne
est un symbole fort :
les 7 péchés capitaux,
les 7 jours de la semaine, le 7ème Ciel.
C’est peut-être pour cette raison que Newton a tenu
à ce que l’arc-en-ciel soit composé de 7 couleurs.
C’est le seul côté obscur de ce personnage des Lumières, mais qui n’a pas fait d’ombre à sa notoriété.
Allez, à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
« capsule de déconfiné lungo »
et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes déconfinés,
mais on reste en lien.